SO THE AUTHO "
JUSTICE."
THANK YOU BOTHTYOFWANT TTH
SER WICKERRT BSTO TH EXACTLY
SAIDN HIS ILLING A CAM SE AND H
MAAYG  T UNCONSTITUTIONAL.ATKS
DI>> NOT AT ALL.BICAFFIRMATIVE L
YO IWE'VHAE LE
400 YEAR BD YET WEACYALE,
PRINCETOCKE
LOOKED UPOYTHINGTH
AVE TH
HITE FT TUAL MINDS.E S UN
SO THE BEEA DG COURT
JUDGE IN T 1960sD THESE
BEYOND REPROAC TO THEIR , YES,T.
MATTER WHATS
UNDERMINE EI AND HHASN'TED ANY O
THR QUIC
DOESKNDE BINATE. TENT TOK  AT TS
HAS HE MADE ON
COURT?
>> YEAS
LEGACY THAT HE WILL LEAVE ON THE
COURT.
HERIO MA LEADI  ANDG OPINIONSN ,
RAHE HASN NG
RRINLITICAL
T STRONG LEGACYIN THAT NS
SAESUMESULL  THERLRITES THAT PRN
THERROWN SON, AN APS JUDG NUD SS
TE
U. DICT J. MISHE IS ON SOUTH C.
THESE SIV
AND AYS, WHIC
RESUMES, WHICH ONE
YOKE THINK
E COURT
IS THE COURT THAT IS TO
UPREME COURT
ALTELL CASES. BACKGA LACLON A AH
A COURTD WE A UTOURT OF APPEALC
COURT.TH J
DIAND, YOU KHESE WOM ALL  T THEL
YOIRCUIT, THESARE
AND LEONDRA KRUGER.
WOMEN THAT WOULD PREVENTU.S. SNS
ANY N HERE FOR THEIRTO T CFA
THATHEK ANN
NONA BLACK WDETHAT HE WAG FORWD
E IS THIIDD ORY ANRESSION  THIN
HAVEPON ASTEL CANDIDATES AND T
O HAVE COMD DURINGADNI TTHAS
MINUTEITAME THAT I. CHRISTINE,
THOUGHTSNTIAL
NOMINEES.
>> YEAH, TOICES AR
ENTIALS.SHE STLI
AND SHE WAR JUSTICBREYER.
AND ALSO LEORAEXEN
SHD  SOLICITOR
KEY CASES BEFORECOURT.
AND ISNE WHO ALSO CLER
EPHENS ON THE SULINGEDD JUDGE C
ANCE THAMA MIGHT ADD
AN INTTIE OF
PRSIERSITYAND I K  MANY OF THE
RS I EASIETH
JUE RESTA RO
THE LEGAL ACADY MIT EASIER T